mientras haya luz esta unidad de
voluntarios de las defensas
territoriales elevan sus drones en busca
de posiciones rusas a menos de 6 km
de lo que descubran depende que el
trabajo del batallón infantería al que
pertenecen tenga éxito esta es una
guerra donde los drones son tan
importantes como la artillería
nosotros somos los ojos la artillería es
el puño
las coordenadas de las posiciones
enemigas son dadas a otras unidades que
se encargan de detener su avance esta es
una tarea de gran responsabilidad para
hombres como kiril que hasta el 24 de
febrero regentaba un restaurante de
hamburguesas
tengo muchos amigos que operan drones
para filmar carros y hacer vídeos
aprendí a hacerlo con ellos si no llega
ya letal este es el punto donde se
coordina la información de ellos depende
que el enemigo no quiebre la defensa y
las unidades actúen a tiempo aquí
también todos son civiles que hace cinco
meses se unieron a las defensas
territoriales creadas para dar apoyo a
las fuerzas ucranianas al comienzo de la
guerra hoy están integradas al ejército
de estar destinadas a tareas como
retenes muchas de estas unidades han
terminado a cargo de misiones
estratégicas pasan la mayor parte del
tiempo en este refugio habilitado para
que las comunicaciones no se quiebren ni
en los momentos más duros
la manera que tenemos para igualarlos en
el campo de batalla es ser creativos y
responder rápidamente
wilco robots
el comandante blatt es miembro del
parlamento en la ciudad de kiev esta es
una de las trincheras utilizadas por los
hombres en momentos de ataques señala
que en frente está en el partido dos
grupos de rusos
el peor de todos es el primer cohete lo
oímos disparar pero no sabemos dónde va
acá en la web usted para estos hombres
la experiencia ha sido mucho más dura lo
que algún día pensaron como una moral
para pelear es buena más allá de toda la
situación va bien porque sabemos que
somos capaces de destruirlos gracias a
nuestros equipos de reconocimiento y
artillería
reconocen que la llegada de algunas
armas occidentales ha dado un impulso a
la moral en el frente